peter king about to join us so i booked
peter um
yesterday i text him during nfl game day
morning and
um he's been doing this lately and i
hope he doesn't mind that i share it
with my audience
but it's fun it's it just gives you
window into what a delightful human
peter king is
uh so i got i feel a buzz in the return
on my text
and i'm i look down and it is peter's
number and this is what popped up on my
phone
you know i'm free for your show you
absolutely
know that i'm free for your show
there you go so peter king
bitmoji guy he is bitmoji i mean he is
beyond bitmoji i think if i look at my
text exchange with peter king who's
going to join us when our radio audience
returns in just 30 seconds
i've got a bear two bears a koala
on my phone has he used the giraffe yet
there's a giraffe yeah the draft's
that's right i didn't know that the
unicorn
back here on the rich eisen show uh pete
family's gonna talk about college
football uh steve kornacki who was uh
awesome on sunday night football
football night in america last night
he's gonna join us in hour number two
and damian woody from espn and my buddy
who i just showed
to the peacock audience radio audience
that he's a bitmoji responder
thankfully he responded positively it'd
be difficult to get a uh i can't do it
or i won't do it
response when uh the emoji is like a
dinosaur
as a t-rex okay uh peter king how are
you peter
rich i i don't know i discovered that
and now i'm being totally ridiculously
obnoxious
no you're not it's delightful peter it's
if i great john lynch i don't i don't
send him one of those i probably should
he'd get a kick out of him you would
you know but uh yeah if i take sean
payton i'm probably not gonna be sending
him the
uh the little kitten the kitten uh
bit emoji or whatever they're they're
called you're never gonna have fun with
it you do and it's it's it's great to
have you here and i appreciate you
uh t-rex or koala or bear just uh
agreeing to do the show as always
so uh i guess let's get into the the
story of the moment that greg williams
has been fired as a defensive
coordinator i just did see in the
commercial break speaking of emoji
the head slap emoji that uh quinn and
williams
the uh one of the the few jets on
defense that uh were drafted and are
working out
uh i i i he might not be agreeing with
this it was a head slap emoji from quinn
williams i i give you the floor on what
what what's went down over the last 24
hours of the jets
i mean really i'd say to quinn and
williams or anybody i mean does it
really matter
you know i have a feeling that the
outcry over the last
you know whatever 16 hours or whatever
however long before they
actually fired them all they are feeding
somebody of the wolves
you know the jets what can they do they
just
they're gonna fire everybody at the end
of the year what does it matter greg
williams gets a four week vacation
and he gets a tremendous uh
thing on his resume he's the only
defensive coordinator
i think in nfl history to have
coordinated defenses for teams that went
over
you know the browns in 2017 0 and 16
and the jets in 2020 uh 0 and 12.
so you know who knows but rich
i i must say that
even a football neophyte who
who has not watched much football would
ask
this question do you mean to tell me you
did not give
any safety help to
lamar jackson who this lamar jackson
was an undrafted free agent
rookie cornerback from nebraska
going up against um the most desirable
fastest receiver in this year's draft
and going up against him with no
chance of any help dude you're out on an
island
with henry ruggs iii and
good luck and that's what the jeff said
to him
it was foolish and look i'm not i don't
root for anybody to lose
his his or her job but
i i i thought that was an awful awful
decision by greg williams now he makes
those decisions often
and if it worked and they sacked them
sack fumble
all that stuff you know everybody would
be
oh boy that greg williams man riverboat
gambler
but when it doesn't work um and you lose
the game because of it
uh you deserve to be held accountable
peter king here
on the rich eisen show well let's talk
about teams that are i i would say there
are
um closer to relevance uh the eagles
though
are dwindling in that department and um
right now as you and i are talking doug
peterson is meeting with the
philadelphia media after putting
uh jalen hurts into the game for the
eagles benching carson wentz finally
against green bay uh hurts did not uh
look
lost at all he actually provided
the spark that's necessary earlier today
on the radio doug peterson said he still
had not made a decision
uh as to who would start against the
saints what is going on there and is
doug peterson howie roseman
is is everybody in trouble there right
now
you know i don't know that's a good
question i wouldn't be surprised if doug
was in trouble
um you know it's it's a little bit sad
if he is
because i think he's a good coach who i
think in my opinion
the mistakes that he's made this year
have been made
because he's trying to make something
positive happen and the fact is
that it's hard to make something
positive happen when your quarterback in
your offensive line
are both terrible and unfortunately
that is what he's dealing with this year
um in my opinion when you wake up on
monday morning
and you don't commit to your quarterback
you're probably going to change your
quarterback
in my and in my opinion too i think it's
a smart decision
and again not that this means that
uh carson wentz's eagles career is over
because i don't think it is
but i do think that after a while
especially in a voracious town like
philadelphia
with the fans and the media after a
while
you've just got to for kind of the
mental health
of your quarterback and your team you
got to try something else
that's what i would do if i were him and
i think he probably will do it
peter king here on the rich eisen show
in your history of uh covering this
sport your lush
uh history pete rozelle winner and and
so on and so forth or i'm sorry about a
mccann award winner
uh at the pro football hall of fame has
has there ever been a five and seven
coach
thrown into the mix for coach of the
year as joe judge
uh appears to be right now peter well
you think back to when they were
0-5 and um
they looked like absolute lost sheep in
the past year of life
and and since then you know
they're they're five and two and if you
take the two games they lost
uh they lost very narrowly to
philadelphia and they lost a game that
honestly uh daniel jones threw away
against the bucks
at home on a monday night uh they should
have beaten tom brady
and so i think what has happened with
the giants
is that you basically see i mean this is
a team that
in this highest scoring one of the
highest scoring most offensive
seasons in nfl history the giants over
the last seven weeks are giving up 19
points a game
which is fairly incredible especially
when you have very few household names
even in their own households on that
defense
so i think joe judge and patrick graham
jason garrett have really done a
terrific job in making a non-competitive
team
competitive so i'll ask you a question
that might be
uh jumping the gun a little bit here but
you know the way as you mentioned
coach's talk
after uh after on a monday joe judge
said that
joe judge said that the team would give
uh daniel jones every chance to prove
that he can
he can be healthy enough to play does
that mean there's a door open for colt
mccoy
uh a more veteran hand here that joe
judge could actually turn to because as
you know
i don't think there's a sacred cow in in
with joe
judge that's right that's what i've kind
of learned for the first time
you know what i think he's doing i think
he's basically saying that
i am not putting daniel jones back in
the lineup until
a he can run around very similar to what
he usually does and be
so that he can protect himself i don't
think he is leaving
the door open for colt mccoy to beat out
uh beat out daniel jones but but let's
just say for the sake of argument
that colt mccoy plays again on sunday
against arizona
that arizona's got to come across the
country again
like they did last week to new england
played poorly and lost um
to me i i if i were cliff kingsbury by
the way i'd be watching that giants tape
and i would be
i don't want to say the word frighten
but i would think oh my god
we looked at the schedule at the
beginning of the year and we're saying
oh good we got a
trip to east rutherford in december
that'll be good
well all of a sudden it's not looking so
good but
no i i don't think he is uh
dangling the starting the permanent
starting carrot
in front of colt mccoy's face i i think
that daniel jones gets the job back when
he's ready
okay a few minutes left here with peter
king on the rich eisen show
suss out the the bottom of the nfc wild
card race right now i mean the vikings
are your seventh seed
the niners tonight have an opportunity
to join
uh the uh the vikings at six and six and
then you've got a team in arizona
that is appearing to just absolutely
fall apart
and uh i i'm wondering how you know you
look at this you got the bears at five
and seven
the lines at five and seven are a
different completely different five and
seven cause they just want to get to
that mark
walk me through with the bucks coming
off of a buy sitting in front of this
group
by just one game right here how do you
assess it my feeling is
san francisco is right now today
even playing mcmullens more
of a a better team to me than either
minnesota or
arizona uh but again
it won't matter if they don't beat
buffalo tonight and but if they do beat
buffalo
i think we would all say okay they're
they are
coming back and while they're keeping
the seat warm for kittle and garoppolo
who will come back
most likely for the last two games
they are i think they're a dangerous
team right now that team that went to la
last week and won
they got a they have a better defense
than they should have
you know without bosa and then you know
now getting richard sherman back
um i i think i think i would respect
them the most if they got to six and six
i thought it was interesting last night
that steve kornacki using
pro football focus numbers yes had
arizona
so much more highly respected
than uh than the vikings
which i thought was just odd quite
honestly because
i've watched arizona play and i know
they got to come to
play the giants um you know on sunday
and then they
they still have two nfc west games left
in the last three weeks i i don't i
don't
i i don't share pff's uh
love of the cardinals right now well
maybe neither do i to be quite honest
with you or maybe they're just looking
at minnesota
um who has a visit to tampa next
and then have got uh a date and they got
to go to new orleans
right so that that might be just like
looking at everything
considered but uh if cousins doesn't
make mistakes
they have potentially the best running
back in the nfl
when healthy behind him or next to him
and dalvin cook
and this kid justin jefferson uh
jefferson is
amazing a rookie receiver right as i've
seen come into the league
as a rookie uh in years exactly he is so
smooth so fast he he reminds me too rich
if you
watch him he reminds me he's got a
little bit of physicality to him that
really
might surprise you a little bit he knows
already when he can be physical when he
can get away with something he reminds
me of michael irvin a little bit
michael irvin was always the king of
uh the push-off right at the last second
so that nobody could see it
unless you look very very carefully he
was great at it
and i think justin jefferson has a
little bit of
all of that uh in him right now and
you know it's amazing rich when you
think about
this that justin jefferson basically was
traded straight up and not even straight
up because the vikings got more out of
it
a fourth fifth and sixth round pick but
he was traded straight up for stephon
dix
and he will make less in the next four
years than stephon dix makes
this year so you say boy
you know everybody was killing the
vikings for losing digs
and i get it but digs also
led to a lot of drama in minnesota
and here's a drama-free guy at a very
low cost
who could catch 400 balls in the next
four
years it's i'm wild by him really
honestly
last one for you peter king uh a team is
you know the old parcells axiom you are
what you are
and uh at nine and three uh you are a
nine
and three team and in a vacuum let's not
look at the history
uh obviously but in this vacuum when
you've got a quarterback not making any
mistakes
uh five straight games of that
interception and you've got a two-headed
monster at running back behind an
offensive line that bill callahan is
coaching and is totally remade and a
defensive player of the year candidate
and a defense that has balling out and a
head coach that is clearly
uh getting bought what he is selling you
you've got an outstanding football team
are they cl
where do you term the cleveland browns
right now where do you
place the thing with the browns look the
browns yesterday in my opinion
basically made the playoffs so now
the whole issue is at the top of the afc
obviously has two teams at the very top
and again not i'm not trying to get
ahead of
anything right now but the biggest
question about the browns
is are they in position
to be able to beat pittsburgh in kansas
city
on the road within eight days that's the
big question
you know and and look i think it's it's
easy for us to sit here and say well you
know just
take it take it in stages if they could
win one playoff game this year
if they could win let's say at indy or
or at tennessee or
you know whatever at buffalo let's say
who knows but if they could win one
playoff game
that is a tremendous accomplishment and
it is
it is but i'm trying to look ahead i
and again i'm not saying it's easy to
win a playoff game
but cleveland is playing so well right
now and played so well yesterday
other than the second half on defense
um that you're starting to say is it
possible
that they could win more than one
playoff game in january
it's possible but i i still think
pittsburgh and
and kansas city and the afc right now
are kind of cut above
i don't know uh we said the same thing
about tennessee last year and they
they one and done tom brady and then
went ahead and won and done lamar
jackson
and what a tennessee question they had a
quarterback who didn't make mistakes in
a running game that was very difficult
and a defense that was opportunistic and
the offense could go up top when they
needed to off a play-action game it was
respected
because of the running game that to me
sounds like the cleveland browns
peter you're right but just remember
just remember
six seeds like tennessee are rare
yeah and just because it happened in
2019
it doesn't mean that it's going to
happen this year but you
you know what if baker mayfield throws
downfield with the accuracy that he did
yesterday and if he doesn't turn it over
the browns can win any game they play
peter thanks for the time
really appreciate everybody check out
for good morning in america thanks for
the call peter
you got it that's peter king hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here